عرض امريكي باستئناف جهود وقف النار في
السودان بيد انه مرهون بجديه الطرفي
النزاع في الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار كشرط
اساسي وفق ما اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه واشنطن اعربت عن اسافها من قرار
الجيش السوداني وقف المحادثات معتبره ان
الخطوه تصاعب وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى السودانيين
انه امر مؤسف انسحاب احد اطراف الصراع في
السودان اذ نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات الى المدنيين فمن الصعب عليها
الان ان تصل الى من هم في امس الحاجه
اليها كالغذاء والماء والدواء لذلك من
المؤسف للغايه انهم اختاروا تعليق
المحادثات نريدهم ان يختنموا فرصه السلام
على محمل الجد ونحن بالتاكيد جدون في
المساعده وفي تسهيل هذه المحادثات
الخطوه جاءت بعد تبادل الاتهامات بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الجيش من جانبه اوضح
ان تعليق مشاركته في محادثات جده مع الدعم
السريع برعايه سعوديه امريكيه بسبب عدم
التزام قوات الدعم السريع ببنود الهدنه
واتهمها بالفشل في الايفاء بالتزاماتها
كما راى انه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديد
الهدنه في ظل الخروق التي ترتكبها قوات
الدعم السريع
اما قوات الدعم السريع فقد اكدت التزامها
بالمفاوضات مشيره الى ان الجيش تعمد تعطيل
الهدنه
على الارض دوي اطلاق النار لا يتوقف في
مناطق متفرقه بالخرطوم والولايات
والوضع الانساني يمضي من سيء الى اسوا
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات